Machine knitters will often scrap off
their knitting and rehang the stitches.
This is equivalent to putting stitches
on a holder and hand knitting
to temporarily pause your knitting.
You might scrap off and rehang to turn
the work and knit some purl rows,
or you might scrap off some shoulder
stitches on a sweater and then rehang
those stitches of both
shoulders to join the seam.
Scrapping off is just knitting a few
rows with the contrasting color yarn.
Now, if your yarn isn't slippery or
the piece isn't going to be handled a lot,
it isn't necessary to bind off the scrap.
Just drop the knitting from the machine.
When it's time to rehang the knitting
on the machine,
start by putting the required number
of needles into working position.
To make things easier, open the latches.
I'm just using the edge
of a business card.
Use a single or double
prong transfer tool.
Ignore the scrap, in this case the blue
yarn, and put the tool
in the garment stitches.
In this case, the pink stitches.
Next, hang the eye of the tool over the
hooks of the needles on the needle bed.
Lift the tool and slip those stitches
off the tool and onto the needles.
Make sure you haven't caught any
of that scrap yarn or split the stitches.
Repeat this until all the required
stitches are back on the machine.
Now, you can remove the scrap right now
and confirm your pickup or leave
the scrap in place, just in case.
Picking up stitches from scrap is
an essential skill that will become
second nature the more you work it.